welcome to kickers anonymous let's  introduce ourselves because no one's  ever heard of us I'm Stephen Houska who  exactly I'm Dustin Hopkins you may know  me  because I missed the game-winner in Week  eight and I'm Roberto Aguayo and I'm a  huge disappointment lately ah Snickers  suck can why'd they make the extra  points harder it's too much pressure  so much pressure I want to puke just  thinking about it I can puke on cue now  check this out oh you can the puke  bucket  I just miss it Adam Vinatieri  that's right it's me Adam Vinatieri the  best kicker in the world and I know the  secret about kicking nobody gives a  about any of us thanks for coming to my  baby shower everybody from one star QB  to another a goofy outfit for when your  baby needs to distract the media from a  bad season Russel is happening the  baby's coming  what okay I'll catch you Sarah you're  doing great Malcolm Butler should have  handed it off